Jojo Fletcher is one week into filming
the latest season of The Bachelorette
and et is rounding up the scoop from the
show creator Mike Fleiss wife says that
this season is gearing up to be the
quote most dramatic ever here are a few
things we know about the newest season
of The Bachelorette our new bachelorette
Jojo 24-year old Texas native has
embarked on her journey to find love and
according to the female crew members on
set Fletcher has the quote hottest cast
guys I'm so excited Fleiss who has been
tweeting up a storm writes Jojo has
already kissed four and a half men
that's crazy and that some conversations
are getting to be a bit too steamy for
TV The Bachelorette creator reveals at
least two of the cast members butt heads
Monday writing quote two of the guys
nearly came to blows last night and
according to producers one of the group
dates was quote the most dramatic ever
Mike also shared Jojo is taking this
very seriously she really did love Ben
and wants what Lauren has and he gave us
a behind-the-scenes pic of Jojo bachelor
nation get ready the new season of The
Bachelorette airs May twenty-third on
ABC